you know what Harry's guest has a
first-hand experience of the charity
work that the Prince began in southern
Africa you might be able to hear one of
the bands coming down the street and the
excitement is done
well anyway their friendship grew out of
Harry's commitment to help children in
dire conditions Charlie d'Agata is on
Kings Road with the story Charlie
yes hello Kevin Prince a co is the
brother of the king of the African
nation of the suti now way back in 2006
he and Harry set up the center bow a
charity to help some of the most
vulnerable children in the world
everywhere he goes I think it is he
bonds a lot faster not quicker with the
children what is he like with children
Harris is one big child basically you go
to any party listen to where Harry has
beed and you get in a truthful honest
and a straight answer as a child you
know how a child reacts was I yes or no
do you love Harry
we love him why we don't know but he's
just one of us that's how they react to
him
I love children and nicest thing I hear
is they don't know who I am
I'm just a normal guy then I could see
in Harry that here's somebody who wanted
to get his hands dirty if I couldn't say
that he wasn't afraid to say me to pick
up a child who was hiv-positive
he wasn't afraid to step into and talk
to a disabled person who who was
mentally or physically disabled so I
mean the early days he was he was still
there
meaning they in a sense of participating
holy lee but recently you can see that
his grown and his opinions are very
informed because he's seen how we have
grown and instance about looking forward
to the wedding oh it's gonna be a
glorious day everybody's very excited
especially especially the children they
have grown they've seen him grow they
say okay well congratulations to him
he's like family
yes exactly he's more than family I mean
like I said he's a brother well you
couldn't have asked for a better
ambassador than Prince Harry now the
Prince told me that he hasn't met Megan
Markel but he believes that together
there will be an unstoppable force that
will have a continued commitment to the
charity gala
all right thank you very much charlie
dug it up